I want to read you about this is the
column where they answer some of the
real problems that we have today in
marriage okay now I don't want you guys
to take this lightly I want to pretend
like we are answering This Woman's
question okay dear
Jessica that's the girl's name my
husband wakes me up in the middle of the
night wanting sex
I struggle to fall back asleep
afterwards and have told him so I wake
up very early for work each day so the
fact that he continues to awaken me
troubles me because I am not getting
adequate sleep when I bring this up he
claims I wake him up and that he is
trying to satisfy me I feel like he's
gaslighting me but he and continues to
insist it is my doing how do I help
now I want to First give you guys
what this woman said to her now we'll
see do women give good relationship
advice no okay
let's let's give her the benefit of the
doubt yeah she's like it's a waste of
time all right look look good
it's possible your husband is lying to
you
to justify to justify his habit of of
waking you for sex and it's also
possible possible you're experiencing
some form of what it what is known as
sex insomnia
get one of those little surveillance
cameras that record the movements
I wish I had that problem only because
only because the camera is only to do
one thing is to underline who is the
actual culprit because she said that he
said it's her she said it's him so you
get the camera out and you prove who did
it yeah but what are you just not what
are you just not complaining just do it
yeah
what's gonna happen so they get the
camera and they're like aha he's doing
it then what yeah
I want to give up I want to give a
proper shout out to our friend Ali Real
Fem Sapien she gave a really good book
that I think a lot of women and men
should read it's the proper care and
feeding of husbands by Dr Lauren
Schlesinger has anybody read that book
I think you're on commission or
something how many books have you
mentioned I've read a lot no verse
um so you know that's a really good book
for women to understand like what men
really want and Dr Lawrence does really
really really good job at it but maybe
that wouldn't be an issue if she was
being fulfilled each time
[Music]
you know he's like cheers you know and
she's like what the hell we just started
maybe she said for a week maybe she said
it keeps her awake after she never said
that he was bad she said so maybe it's
Ross in it and then maybe he's thinking
you know what it's a good session I can
go back to sleep there because women do
wake up once you've had sex I just I
thought it was your duty to have sex
with your husband so obviously yeah like
like marriage is an exclusive sexual
contract If you deny your partner of sex
like who is he supposed to go get it
from
yeah but even in the military you're not
always on duty you're only on duty on
certain time like no you're always on
duty
like say if you are the horse guard
you're great you only am due to while
you standing
now you get to be a wife when you feel
like it yeah what I'm trying to say is
you always use these negative words and
negative connotation like for me this is
this is part like what was negative
about doing your duties because for me
that's not a dude it's a pleasure yes
what if I wanted to find pleasure what
if I wanted to find pleasure with
another woman
so he's weak for sleeping with another
girl but the girl's not but the way
around wait but the girl is not weak for
not sleeping with her husband let's get
let's get real I'm sorry but I really
need to put an end to to this like oh
what should we do we should do whatever
we want in the end no you shouldn't do
whatever you want that is complete
that's the selfish nature that's gonna
get your ass alone and dying with a dog
did it get you recently I hear but
listen let me just uh go don't look at
me I'm just saying like you you you're
bringing you know to me and like oh
shouldn't be doing wait wait what did
what get me or what
back up your statement
I'm not gonna even go into this okay
fair play but you brought it up
he didn't insult you no I'm not
insulting me finish you're insulting him
personally what do you need an insult I
didn't mean to insult him that probably
came out wrong but you can't say that
it's okay I have this effect on women on
the podcast I have this effect I'm
afraid you know but I I you can't go
immediately use that or I'll go sleep
with somebody you have to respect that
we are not machines women are not
machine it's a must no no
but his point was that she said it's
about pleasure and so he's saying if
it's about pleasure yeah I didn't I
didn't mention listen with my men
no no no no no no no not on the clock or
off the clock let me add some contacts
let me let me add some contacts what I'm
trying to say let me add some context to
the statement that I made I didn't say
my wife was neglecting me sexually but
you don't because just listen again
allow me to finish my sentence sure and
add some context to this theoretical
situation we're talking right now I was
saying because you mentioned was about
pleasure I said so what if another woman
were to offer me pleasure outside of the
relationship but I mean you always bring
in other women let's bring in let's do
it
can I can I say something in her support
no let's go there's only one Queen same
way for me there is only one king and
that means to be enough
but Kings throughout history have always
had concubines if we're gonna go back I
don't care who has what I am
in like I know my analogy seemed to be
funny for you but my analogy they fit
into what I am the analogy is not funny
but I mean this is the Andrew tight
argument isn't it where the wife is the
the kid the head woman she is my she is
my queen she is that she is the queen
absolutely but that doesn't mean that he
won't necessarily
on occasion entertain which is fine but
my my he would never be my man that
that's the only thing
I I don't need to give anyone advice
what you're saying is like it's about my
pleasure and it's all about me that's
not what I said wait yes you just said
it's about pleasure this is just Twisted
now yeah it's about just twisting if you
are married you can make all the
comments in the world if you're not in a
marriage just assuming that's how it
should be yeah yeah
the response to that to that scenario is
this they should just compromise if if
it's an issue if it's that much of an
issue for her then she said don't wake
me up in the middle of the night but
yeah I'll wake you up in the right way
yeah yeah
I just agree I really think sex is a
duty I think you're supposed to listen
to your husband
[Applause]
happening because the thing is I'm
engaged so I'm not allowed to talk about
it yeah no but this is the thing it's
like when women don't like it's so
feminine it's like
it's like like what you have to say
they'll attack you personally and she
started to do it to you she does it to
me but it's like is what we're saying
true or is it not true to bring the
before a woman hates my message the more
I know I'm on the right path
you took it away from reality because
the the original discussion was about
being woken at the middle of the night
nobody can deal with sleep depravity
very well I was woken up last night by a
woman who wanted to have sex with me and
I didn't want to have sex
I was enduring last night no no I was
literally enduring last night
it's a persistent
I am not going to be with that person
for very long that's the reality of the
conversation but what's Johnson
s are putting out but for the team you
endured I didn't want her to make a hit
piece on me online
you know I think I can see if on both
sides of the coin I think if if I've
never been in a relationship where I've
Ever Wanted sex or not I'm being refused
that's um this doesn't ever happen so I
can't really relate but I can imagine
how frustrating it would be I think if
but I also agree if you're if she's
asleep and you're waiting for her to go
to sleep then waking up for sex that
can't be nice for over a long period of
time if it's someone off here and there
yeah you should do it but I just think
if you're waiting for it to go to sleep
I think they can be compromised I think
if you love her you would and you
respect her you don't have to just think
oh well that's what I wanted is
compromise but also if she's asleep and
you need it or sometimes wake up yeah yo
but but I think my point is the mindset
it's not even about the action it's like
you're supposed to have a selfless
mindset in marriage it's not supposed to
be about you yeah yeah that was my point
when they were talking it was always
about them it's about my pleasure yeah
don't confuse it please what I said
about pleasure don't confuse use it
please don't I know it's easy to point
fingers and say that's what you think
but let me just clarify it again what I
said about pleasure is you said you also
said I'm not on the clock 24 7 so that's
me yes so I'm talking about Duty for me
duty is a negative connotation where
it's pleasure my man's pleasure for me
is a positive pronunciation
give me a chance to explain so you say
you're looking at the same coin from a
different but one sounds a little bit
uncomfortable whereas the other one
makes you know it feels like I I would
always pleasure my man I don't need to
have a duty not to pleasure my man
I rather call it volunteering work you
know I I understand what you're saying
those two sounds very different I get
you but if a burglar breaks into the
house it's not my pleasure to go and
defend my families my duty to go and
defend my family yes but that's
different you're talking about burglar
I'm talking about my husband it's not
it's not a burglar no I think the
husband the same thing because he's
talking about when he has to do
something he doesn't want to do and
we're talking about it's different this
is a protective mode you're protecting
your family
back to my marriage from giving it yes
but it's still protection you manage
from sleeping with your man when you
don't want to so he doesn't go in he
he's not even playing wait wait he's not
even protected he's not even protecting
I'm protecting I'm actually sustaining
my marriage by being with myself because
we just love to do whatever but what Ty
said is is even more if you want to rank
it right
when someone's burglaring your house
he's risking the ultimate asset his life
to protect your life
yeah but we slide we you were talking
about someone waking you up in the
middle of the night to have some fun
times and now then all of a sudden you
ended up in a place where someone is
coming to attack us yeah
for me I would rather have a you know I
like I understand what you mean any Duty
in a sense but to see your whole
marriage as a woman or as a man as a
duty I understand why people don't want
to get married you should have sex every
night how would you react if he said no
to sex for you
I mean I would respect it but he cannot
say no to me too often that's tough
you're gonna go go home get the [__] out
of here get out of here you cannot make
it up so listen why why is this
happening across the globe why is this
happening on the whatever podcast why is
this happening on fresh and fit and why
is it happening on the pregame what the
[__] is going on here come on guys but I
also wanted to make a joke
all right
why is this happening
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible